le cinéma en avant première comme tous
les mercredis avec une nouvelle
production disney un film qui reprend
l'histoire la fameuse histoire des
sorcières de salem
bette midler la célèbre chanteuse rock
est l'une de ces sorcières comme vous
allez le constater elle s'est
considérablement dans les dix à risque
d'effrayer les bambins acquis le compte
est destiné
nicole cornu langlois à salem on
frissonne encore en évoquant les soeurs
winifred sarrail marie 100 personnes qui
mangent les petits enfants
trois siècles plus tard elles reviennent
par une nuit d'halloween je croyais que
vous ne reviendriez jamais mes soeurs et
moi qui vous ai fait réapparaître une
gare d'el ahly fort bien aux rites style
délicieusement feu dans cette farce
fantastico bouffonne tous les moyens
sont bons pour la sorcière bette midler
j'ai adoré tous les effets spéciaux avec
l'eau l'air les trucages sur fond bleu
l'électricité qui sort des mains les
gens qui volent ou qui se transforme en
poussière
le réalisateur qui fut chorégraphe a
gardé un sens aigu du mouvement et
n'hésite pas à employer les effets
spéciaux les plus sophistiqués pour
obtenir les agissements étranges de ses
acteurs
et ne hurlez pas cette tête en réalité
est toujours sur le corps du garçon
pour ce chat noir il a fallu plusieurs
dresseur et l'informatique pour obtenir
qu'il parle
car c'est un garçon transformé par les
sorcières et ce n'est pas de la magie
noire
mais si le corps est vrai la tête
fonctionne grâce à l'ordinateur et aux
images de synthèse
quant aux sorcières elle vole grâce à
des filins d'acier fixé aux cintres du
studio c'était très très difficile il
fallait rester accroché à ce ballet se
suspendre gesticuler et jouer en même
temps c'était vraiment très dur plus
éprouvant pour vous certainement que de
chanter mais tout aussi efficace
les enfants seront fascinés par vaux
sortilèges